hey this is presh talwalkar
assume that both of the following
sentences are true
pinocchio always lies
and
pinocchio says
all my hats are green
we can conclude from these two sentences
that a
pinocchio has at least one hat
b
pinocchio has only one green hat
c
pinocchio has no hats
d
pinocchio has at least one green hat
or e
pinocchio has no green hats
this problem was asked on the 17th
brazilian mathematical olympiad of
public schools
i thank guillerme for the suggestion and
for translating the problem from
portuguese to english
this problem went viral on social media
with tremendous discussion about what
the correct answer is
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
this is a tricky logical puzzle
so let's solve it carefully
first we know pinocchio always lies
here we're not talking about the word
lie in a real world sense where a lie
could be a misleading statement
we are solving a mathematical olympiad
problem
so a lie in this context means a
mathematically false statement
next we know pinocchio says all my hats
are green
what could make all my hats are green a
mathematically false statement
one possibility is that some hat is not
green
another possibility is that perhaps
pinocchio has no hat
in that case when he says all my hats
are green it would seem to be a
mathematical lie
we'll analyze this option in more detail
later
but for now we'll leave these two
options as possibilities
they correspond to answer choices a and
c
so we'll leave these answer choices and
then let's consider each of the other
ones for completeness
answer choice b pinocchio has only one
green hat
is this always true
imagine pinocchio has two green hats and
one blue hat
in that case he could say all my hats
are green and he would be lying
so just from this information we cannot
conclude that pinocchio has only one
green hat
so we'll eliminate answer choice b
what about answer choice d
pinocchio has at least one green hat
well consider if he had two blue hats
he would be lying if he said all my hats
are green
so once again answer choice d is not
always true we can eliminate d as the
answer
answer choice e pinocchio has no green
hats
if pinocchio had one green hat and one
blue hat
he would be lying if he said all my hats
are green
so e is not always correct we'll
eliminate answer choice e
everyone agrees that b d and e should be
eliminated
at this point the social media
discussion was about answer choices a
and c with many people feeling that both
are correct and they would both seem to
be correct
answer choice a pinocchio has at least
one hat
and of course that one hat would not be
green and answer choice c
pinocchio has no hats when he says all
my heads are green that would be a lie
because he has no hats
but in fact answer choice c is wrong
and this is for a logical reason
so let's consider a truth table we have
p q
and if p then q
based on the truth values of p and q
we can assign a truth value to the
statement if p then q
but here's the important part of the
table
if p is false
then the statement if p then q is always
a true statement
a statement is vacuously true if the
premise is false or not satisfied
let me give a concrete example
imagine a room that has no mobile phones
suppose someone said
all mobile phones in the room are turned
off
since there are no mobile phones to
consider
of course all mobile phones in the room
are turned off this is a true statement
but imagine someone else said all mobile
phones in the room are turned on
well since there are no mobile phones in
the room then of course
all mobile phones in the room are turned
on
this is also a true statement
notice each statement is a meaningless
truth because there are no mobile phones
in the room you can pretty much say
anything you want about the mobile
phones because there are no mobile
phones to consider
so apply this concept to the pinocchio
puzzle
imagine pinocchio has no hats
if pinocchio then says all my hats are
green
that would be a vacuously true statement
because pinocchio has no hats he can put
any characteristic he wants on the hats
because he has no
hats that would imply
that pinocchio is actually saying a true
statement
but we know pinocchio only speaks false
statements
therefore he cannot have no hats
answer choice c is wrong
therefore the only correct answer is
answer choice a pinocchio has at least
one hat
what an interesting logic puzzle
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of bind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you